and that's another thing like that we
knew going in we knew that they was
going to be a cocky team which they have
every right to be they was the number
one offense in the in the entire nails
we knew they couldn't block us we knew
that our front four was going to
dominate them so they did us a favor
they played right into our hands we
weren't gonna be that cocky team like
hey we're gonna play them in color one
we're gonna shut them down our best guys
messed up on their best guys we was
gonna make it be a team collective uh
win on defense and that's what we did
man so at the end of the day
they shouldn't even talk about not
having their offensive tackles when they
didn't even help them they put them on
islands by themselves right best pass
wrestlers in the game so that's that's
their own fault
that's buccaneers linebacker devin white
on
undisputed answering a question from
shannon sharp
about whether
white was surprised and the buccaneers
were surprised by the way the chiefs
blocked or didn't block for patrick
mahomes five guys in the protection
scheme 92 percent of the time
white very blunt white white white's one
of my favorite defensive players i think
he may be one of my favorite
talkers either side of the ball because
he says things he says things
and and it's i don't know can anyone
really be offended by that are the
chiefs gonna look at that and say well
there's bulletin board material for when
we meet him again no it's the truth they
chose to not help the backup tackles
they chose to not keep guys in they
chose to say to patrick mahomes we know
you got a bad toe go ahead and run
around on it for 500 yards from the
course of the of the super bowl and uh
buccaneers are the ones that are
throwing a trophy from boat to boat
because of it
you know
the one thing that i think we all
learned
uh watching these playoffs remember at
washington the bucks started it was in
covid protocol
and so he missed that game
and then after that
every single game on defense who was the
best buccaneer defensive player on the
field now we could very easily argue and
i probably would take that argument that
against green bay
that shaq barrett was the best uh
buccaneer defensive player on the field
but overall
you know
in their last uh in their last four
games
their best defensive player on the field
in my opinion uh was was devon white and
think about this mike let me tell you a
very quick story year and a half ago i'm
at buccaneers training camp this is year
before brady so you don't know how good
they're going to be
but anyway there's optimism blah blah
blah and i see
devon white he's walking off the field
he's a rookie i had not asked to talk to
him and i was talking to somebody else
and i looked over and devin white was
walking away and i looked over
and mikey had the green dot on the back
of his helmet
and i said to myself hey wait a second
he's 21 years old and i understand he's
the fifth pick in the draft first guy
taking everything like that
so i tell one of the pr guys hey can i
get a couple minutes with devon white
and i talked to him and i said
you're 21 years old you have the green
dot on your helmet do you have any idea
what that means and for people who don't
really have any idea what it means what
it means is that
the bucks have chosen todd bowles bruce
arians have chosen a 21 year old player
to be the guy who they call signals into
who's going to run the defense
you know for them
on the field at age 21 and so to to see
him now as young as he is
be as dominant as he is be the tackling
machine that he is
in the in the biggest games of his life
is really impressive
and and one of the things that i've
talked to other people about who were in
a position to evaluate
devin white entering the draft there was
a strong belief that this is a guy this
is one of those rare guys
who always is around the football that
troy palamallo ed reed minka fitzpatrick
patrick to a certain extent tyron
matthew just the instincts that always
seem to put him in the right place at
the right time to make the right play
and i've said before peter that if the
nfl had the equivalent of hockey's khan
smythe trophy which goes to the best
player of the entire playoffs even
though white missed the wild card game
yes
i think whites white's the guy white's
the guy whites i think
it was a combination of antoine winfield
and devin white that turned the saints
game around and kept it from becoming a
10 or a 14 point deficit in the third
quarter with the play that was made on
jared cook and the fumble that was
scooped up by white but he's just one of
those guys that always
is around the ball always has a feel for
where the ball is going to be we usually
see those guys one level back it's rare
to see a guy with that kind of
instinct
in the middle linebacker spot usually
it's just to tackle it's for him it's
tackle and
get to the ball when there's an
opportunity to get the ball he's great
and he's awesome and i love what he said
and i'm sure the chiefs have to do some
soul searching peter over why they did
what they did and that that's one of the
questions that i don't know will andy
reid ever really be in a position to
address it will he want to address it
well he hope enough time passes that it
never comes up why in the world didn't
you
help
your overmatched left tackle and right
tackle especially when you knew
that patrick mahomes had a bad toe yeah
yeah i agree
you know it was interesting i was on uh
i was on a podcast last week with the
pro football focus guys who are
obviously the the football nerdy guys
and you know they look at every play
every
player on every play and
and so one of them eric eager asked me
um well
what what really surprised you out of
this super bowl what are the maybe the
two or three things that surprised me
and i said
that andy reid had 30 minutes at half
time in this game and he and eric b
enemy didn't figure out some way
to make patrick mahomes a little bit
better protected in the second half
because it was as bad in the second half
and they did nothing i don't that i saw
anyway consistently to help particularly
andrew wiley who was an absolute
disaster on the right-hand side of the
field i mean if you talk about most
valuable players on the chiefs after
this game i i mean i'm looking at
mitchell schwartz quite honestly as
being one of them because him not being
there and obviously not being there for
the end of the season too
really really hurt kansas city's offense
but
i'm just surprised that especially when
you have an extra long half time that
and maybe there was some small thing
they did technically that was different
they didn't do anything major they
didn't have a six-man line they didn't
have a tight end next to andrew wiley
all the time
and i just think that's a mistake
and and i wonder how aggressively they
tried to pop through the i'm fine i'm
fine facade with mahomes because the toe
was bothering him
and and so if you trust when he says i'm
fine i'm fine and they've been with him
long enough to not that he's played with
a lot of injuries maybe next time around
they'll know to be skeptical when he
says i'm fine because they continue to
to roll with this idea
that mahomes
doesn't need the help because he can run
around and he can make things happen
second half it's amazing what he did
especially given that injury peter i
think that
the fact that the chiefs and everyone
else have seen mahomes work magic
in so many other high profile spots in
single elimination games over and over
again fall behind 10 points no big deal
24 points no big deal i i almost think
that one of the reasons they didn't
change anything is they just thought
patrick's gonna figure it out he always
does
and you know look that's worked a lot
for them in the past but
mike uh
look i'm not here this this is a this is
a full show one day
but i do think
that we have to look at the kansas
kansas city chiefs right now with a
little bit of a jaundiced eye
we just do
because if you take out the last 10
minutes of the fourth quarter of uh
super bowl 54
and you count
um
you know the the other 110 minutes
of the last two games you know what you
have
you have 16 offensive possessions and
one touchdown
and and again
i'm not saying that that the chiefs are
not great they're a great football team
but their performance in the last two
super bowls gives me pause
and it gives me pause that you know if
i'm andy reed i'll never forget
uh when uh
it was either joe banner or howie
roseman you know after andy reid left
uh philadelphia after he got fired and
he went to kansas city
you know the question was
what what do you learn most from andy
reid and his answer was you take care of
both lines
take care of the offensive line in the
defensive line to me their defensive
line's in pretty good shape okay they
need to take take care of their
offensive line and i would be very
surprised
if this if this off season
they don't go heavy
uh on the tackle position on the
offensive line position as a whole
and and they need to be thinking about
having the backups available too what
the patriots always did with the money
that tom brady left on the table having
veteran backups who are making good
money so you don't have to rely upon
some undrafted free agent or a
sixth-round draft pick or somebody you
picked up off the street and you just
hope for the best you know you have
faith you have trust that your backups
are going to be able to step in step up
and get the job done that's one of the
reasons why the patriots won so many
because when the inevitable injuries
happened they had backups who could come
in whom they trusted
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports